we don't tell you a lot about poll
numbers because they're unreliable and
they really are just a snapshot but holy
smokes joe biden's poll numbers are bad
just across the board all americans
disapprove of his border policies his
handling of inflation
the debacle in afghanistan and if all of
that was not enough the daily mail
reporting today that joe biden could be
implicated in an fbi investigation into
his son hunter
to assess all of this is britt hume he's
our senior political analyst here at fox
news and for good reason
brit thanks so much for coming on and i
do this it's not an age question it's a
wisdom question um so
at this moment according to the daily
it's an aids question
just a slim percentage so the daily mail
says that biden may have funded some of
hunter's extracurricular activities and
that they shared
bank accounts if that's true
that sounds like a big deal is it
well it would be a big deal
chuck if it was shown that that you know
that hunter's business activities some
of which are very questionable redounded
to his father's uh uh financial
benefit
uh because you know clearly hunter biden
crossed ethical lines in the in the
activities he engaged in and there was
always this howling conflict of interest
of his serving you know doing business
in ukraine when his father was
responsible for policy related to
ukraine and that's been on the books for
a long time we've all known that if it
were to come out that the joe biden
himself or his campaign or whatever
profited from that that would move the
matter up quite another notch and would
add one more thing
to the reasons why joe biden's
popularity rating has been plummeting as
you pointed out
i hate even to say this but given the
behavior of the attorney general over
the past couple of weeks likening
parents to domestic terrorists can we be
certain that the department of justice
will conduct a a free and fair
investigation into the president's son
and maybe the president
no in a word no yeah the one thing that
this merrick garland has turned out to
be for all of his reputation as being a
fine jurist and a man who deserved
deceit on the supreme court
he appears to be weak as water when it
comes to upholding the independence of
the department of justice and keeping
the justice department out of
politically motivated investigations
um this business of having the fbi
looking into parents behaviors if it was
some kind of terrorism it seems to me is
something that no sensible attorney
general would ever allow to be himself
to be involved in or or give the green
light to and yet he did it so no i don't
think we can depend on that at all uh it
might depend on investigative journalism
to try to uncover this or congressional
investigations if the republicans ever
get control of one or both houses of
congress maybe the new york post will
report on the contents of us await
so i mean given that this story which we
first learned about in october of last
year a year ago was squelched completely
by the media titans
i wonder if we can be certain we'll get
the details this year
well i would think if the new york post
comes forward again with another story
about hunter biden
i
trust and hope at least that the
mainstream media outlets who behave so
disgracefully last year
when the new york post broke the earlier
story would would
would see the arrow their ways and be
willing to pick up the story i would not
expect however
that they would stick their
investigative teams on it they might
just follow the story as it appears you
know day to day that would be about the
most we could hope for but that's a lot
better than nothing which is what we got
last year from these i think politically
corrupt news organizations they'd have
to pull a lot of guys off the q and on
army beat to do that though do you think
they'd be willing
well i think they'd be hesitant um it's
a sad state of affairs but
i think there'd be enough noise made
about this that the whole country would
be able to hear it no question about it
this is the border the the border
situation which was ignored for many
months
by mainstream media outlets finally
broke through so you know these things
can't be suppressed forever at least one
hope's not
so in 20 seconds what effect does this
have on the midterms which are a year
from now
well anything that redounds to the
disapproval of joe biden hurts his party
in the midterms and the president's
approval ratings and standing with the
public is always a major factor in the
midterms especially a president's first
midterm after he takes office uh in
which the president's party historically
does badly so the outlook in the house
at least for the democrats is very poor
and it might spill over to the senate as
well although the map there favors the
democrats but a big wave election would
would sweep the republic the democrats
out in both houses in my view
well deserved britt hume thank you for
that analysis great to see you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else